wait when you go with you all your jokes
you hope that there's obviously there's
different references that they won't get
and some things are very British centric
and I didn't know that if they knew I
have a joke about well it involves the
words hanky-panky what is it
[Laughter]
George oh it's just a silly joke it's a
joke about words that come with another
word so there's like chitchat or chap so
what's the difference being chat and
chitchat why these people say John have
a chance we just had a chat we had a bit
of chit chat but it's pretty much the
same thing the difference of course is
[ __ ] but people never have a chip they
never go would you like a chit no I
don't have time for a chat could we have
a little chit so I was gathered all
these words up like like willy-nilly
nitty-gritty admit to you do sometimes
get the nitty hurly-burly dilly-dally
wishy-washy is hanky-panky
because what everybody hopes I can only
speak as a man but men tend to hope for
hanky-panky on a daily basis but often
we must make do with hanky
[Laughter]
[Applause]
sometimes we get to the end of the day
and it looks like pinkies on the cards
didn't think was happening today and
we're like I'm not sure I can do pinkie
cuz I went hanky early daughter but if
you can refrain from hanky there's a
good chance of rampy bumpy I didn't know
whether they had the phrase hanky panky
in Australia tour manager who is the
sweetest smallest Maltese man he's a
tiny sweet malteaser malteaser with
aboard XO that you've eaten the top of
and I said these those great see I said
grats can you go and find out if they
know the phrase hanky panky because I
don't do this joke and everyone just
stares at me so he went over to the
largest Australian security man I've
ever spent scuse me are you familiar
with the phrase Hank you think
and he's just like you better get away
from me
great junk I'm really familiar with it
yes it went very well
tell me about okay it's not it's not
it's not funny
but it I'm interested in what your
opinion is because you can be
underwhelmed you can be overwhelmed
right but you're never just two days ago
wow you're right like you could be
dischargeable always with like tential
will always go with rady
yeah my favorite is at Kimball you can
only have links I think have you seen
her dance you'll write the whelmed this
is a good fool if I ever went solo that
would be my name well no legs akimbo
please welcome well
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]